BERLIN CRYSTAL
KELLY: To me there
was always the dream of
do really well in finance.
And I wrote down my goal is to
make money and help the world.
I had climbed my way up
through a large multinational
organization.
It was really about
the bottom line.
My lifestyle was going from
my cubicle to a bar stool
to my bed and back.
It wasn't the best for me.
NARRATOR: This is Berlin
Crystal Kelly, and many of us
can probably relate
to her dilemma,
working endlessly to climb
the corporate ladder,
but feeling stuck, uninspired.
Berlin decided she'd had enough.
LAURA LING: So then what
compelled you to make a change?
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY: I'd always
wanted to have my own company.
I decided I was
only going to do it
if I felt like there was
something meaningful I
could do with it, tie it into
something meaningful somehow.
NARRATOR: Like many
young entrepreneurs,
Berlin wanted to
create something
that valued both the planet
and profits in equal measure,
so she started Proud Pour,
a wine label that helps
fund environmental programs.
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY:
We spend about half
of our money on rebuilding
these ecosystems,
and half of our
money on the wine.
To me it's really
important that we
start with fixing our planet,
so we pay the causes first.
NARRATOR: For the past
two years Proud Pour
has been helping to
fund the Billion Oyster
Project, an organization
that restores oyster reefs
in the Hudson River estuary.
This habitat once supported
220,000 acres of reefs,
before they were destroyed
by over harvesting, dredging,
and pollution.
LAURA LING: Why are oysters
so important to the ecosystem?
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY: So
there's a lot of benefits.
One is that one oyster cleans
30 gallons of water per day.
The other thing is that
oysters create reefs,
just like coral reefs do.
So when those reefs
come in, you also
get the crab, sea horses,
starfish, sea bass, shrimp,
everything else starts to
come back and regenerate.
NARRATOR: Naturally
formed oyster reefs are
dependent on old oyster shells.
Young oysters settle on these
old shells and over time,
a reef system is established.
The Billion Oyster
Project reuses shells
from New York restaurants
to engineer this process.
These commercially
farmed oysters help
form the foundation upon
which new wild oysters
can settle and ultimately
rebuild the reef.
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY:
For every bottle
we produce, we restore
100 oysters locally.
And in we've, been able to
restore over 3 million oysters
so far.
The wine was also
really delicious
and sustainably grown,
so it fit our model,
so it really worked out.
LAURA LING: And I hear it
goes very well with oysters.
BERLIN CRYSTAL
KELLY: Yes, it does.
That was part of the idea was
that it would pair with oysters
and more people would be,
hopefully eating oysters
with this wine.
I figured why not
use that industry
to help connect people
to the local environment
and make a change.
LAURA LING: You can drink
your wine, have some oysters,
and feel as though
you are contributing
to the regeneration and
revitalization of these reefs.
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY: Yeah.
LAURA LING: Who knew that
oysters had such power?
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY: I thought
nobody really knows about this,
and this is crazy,
and it's so important.
And it's a solvable problem.
NARRATOR: And Berlin is hoping
socially conscious millennials
will help make the difference.
A generation that's
redefining consumerism
by rewarding companies that
practice social responsibility.
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY:
Forty-two percent
of the wine consumed last
year was by millennials.
But those same millennials
also really care
about global issues,
environmental issues,
social justice.
They're willing to spend more
to support a company that's
doing good work.
NARRATOR: Proud
Pour was recently
featured on Wine Awesomeness,
an online wine club that
highlights distinctive wine
labels and the unique stories
behind them.
It's this kind of
support that's helping
Berlin's company expand.
LAURA LING: So what's next
for you and the label?
BERLIN CRYSTAL KELLY: I was
just in Oregon yesterday
and this weekend, talking
with our next winemakers
about our Pinot
Noir, that's going
to be the pollinator Pinot.
We're going to use
the sales of that
to help native bee
species by planting 3,500
wild flowers for every bottle.
I think it could
really change the role.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe.
And to watch this episode
on a young couple who
gave up their conventional
lifestyle to live on a bus,
click here now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]